hello welcome to this video toilet seat
71 editor it's a name ok so the hanging
game is getting more and more popular
it's so very highly exciting but that's
actually how I feel about many four
positions but this is very awesome
personal preference ok h3 ok yeah ok Pia
Texas a little bit here the CAPTCHA only
five takes on da texif seven I can just
castle though
like to prevent Bishop g5 it's always a
bit of an annoyance and move
so just decided for a very simple
approach the problem is a bit ready for
black to get some life into those
positions you equalize like very easily
but doing something out of this is
really difficult
actually happy that even is doing
something himself so that there's some
some kind of tension building up yes so
this is quite nice from the structural
point of us the a pawn is a little bit
vulnerable at least it could be six here
or not sure about this
I would like to play against the poor
Nia clearly mimicking away five now and
try to trade it off yeah yeah it's not
getting more exciting um and maybe I've
fc5 actually see five
it should win the pawn not so happy for
my d6 bishop but winning a pawn is not
so bad and now rook cheeks is also
interesting rook b6 Queen a 7 it's to a
pretty awkward pinning situation for him
he might be able to correct this though
ok I'm not sure this participant he
won't get that won't get back that
easily yeah night will come to see for
this is definitely not so nice
should be seven maybe just yeah but this
this gives me very nice f-for night
okay you can take their and c5 but
that's not a big deal I've got rooked it
to in this case that's not good at all
Wow
be quite frustrating if that would just
hold easily maybe maybe it does but I do
I cannot quite believe it so Bishop age
three and then queen h4 don't see a
defense here f2 hangs
yeah I know yes it's got no defense
whatsoever okay so interesting
interesting game em Flickr back let's
see EKU went with this deform now h3 m1
tactical point is that if we look at
this check he can win this pawn but
after Luke f8 Bishop back I'm here I'm
completely fine now he played this and I
don't think that I can't afford it to do
this I mean it looks a little bit to
feel now maybe it just doesn't look
right in check yeah maybe HP looks a bit
slow but ok I cancelled all this must be
somewhat okay from both sides and now
okay the capture is very much on the
keep it simple of the keep it simple
kind the easiest is definitely now if
I'm to just trade yeah now I'm getting
something here on the queenside
stabilize the whole thing try to fix the
ape on the engine wants to play c5
immediately and then take a form there I
didn't yet see that idea this is
happening to me quite often that I tend
to overlook moves that are technically
good because they look strategically
like complete lunacy c5 is from a
strategic point of view completely
idiotic yeah it weakens diva be 5d five
kills the bishop yeah our good never did
win still very important a coupon so I
did
even consider c5 i only hear considered
it probably because some other most
don't test white at all yeah this was
maybe a clever idea provoking f3 it cost
i think this is definitely nice now yeah
okay the computer finds a much stronger
defense now Bishop to see one yeah
that's a better building up this one
this pin and it evaluates the position
as equal this is this is good leading to
issues bishopston c1 still playable this
is losing him yeah this is losing he has
got no defense now g2 is collapsing it
here there is no move kingi wonders look
F to check and yeah he doesn't have
anything like this nor check so he
resigned them with full justification
okay well thanks for watching